the opening scene takes place in
war-torn Iraq where gunshots and
explosions can be heard at any given
time in one such City a bomb Specialist
Team from the U.S spots a homemade
explosive also known as an IED as a
result the military quickly evacuates
the area and the bomb disposal unit led
by Sergeant Matt Thompson takes charge
their plan is to use an advanced robotic
drone to destroy the bomb Sergeant
Thompson believes that by using plastic
explosives they can safely detonate the
IED from a distance to carry out the
operation a small cart is affixed to the
back of the robot drone which is then
dispatched into the area designated for
the explosion however just before
reaching the IED the trailer loses one
of its Wheels this makes the operation a
complete failure now with time running
out Matt decides to inspect the
situation himself he dons a bulky bomb
suit and proceeds to the trailer while
his two teammates named Sergeant JT
Sanborn and specialist Owen remain
behind Vigilant of their surroundings
Matt lifts the trailer and trans
transports it to the IED carefully
setting it up as intended but as he
makes his way back Owen notices that a
man in a butcher shop is using a cell
phone he frantically alerts Sanborn and
rushes towards the man instructing him
to drop the phone but unfortunately the
man quickly dials a specific sequence of
numbers triggering the bombs explosion
this kills poor Matt on the spot after
the tragic loss of their fellow Soldier
Sanborn gathers Matt's personal
belongings and prepares them to be sent
home in a casket Upon returning to the
base he meets with the new team leader
of the bomb disposal unit Sergeant
William James who is currently removing
the plywood covers from his windows
Sanborn advises James to keep them on
due to the risk of mortar shrapnel but
James dismisses the suggestion stating
that the covers would be ineffective if
a mortar shell were to crash through the
unit's roof why bother wearing a bike
helmet if you could get hit by an
asteroid the following day the unit
receives a report of another IED located
on a narrow Street in the city upon
arrival they meet up with another Army
platoon that had discovered covered the
bomb the leader of the platoon informs
them that the bombs are located 20
meters down the street in response James
puts on a bomb suit and proceeds alone
the entire incident is being observed by
local residents from their rooftops and
windows as James approaches the bombs
area he throws a smoke grenade claiming
it is for diversionary purposes this
action causes agitation among his team
members as they are unable to see him
clearly upon reaching an intersection a
car stops in front of James prompting
him to point his gun at the driver other
soldiers in the vicinity surround the
car and instruct the driver to exit the
vehicle but despite their commands the
defined individual refuses to comply in
response James fires a shot at the car's
front window places his gun against the
man's forehead and demands that he moved
the vehicle backward eventually the
driver agrees and gets back where the
other soldier's apprehend him and take
him away shortly after James comes
across an artillery shell hidden beneath
a small pile of garbage which she easily
disarms he believes that the task is
complete but soon discovers is a
secondary wire pulling out its
connection he realizes it is linked to
six more bombs he then proceeds to
disarm all the bombs without any fear
during this an unknown guy secretly
watches James from a nearby building and
upon witnessing his defusing efforts the
person hurriedly descends the stairs
with the successful completion of their
mission James rejoins his teammates and
Sanborn advises him to improve his
communication during operations and not
treat his duties as a solo Endeavor
however James dismisses the advice
without much consideration the next day
James is walking outside the military
base when a young boy named Beckham
approaches him offering to sell DVDs
after persistent requests James agrees
and purchases one from the merchant whom
the boy works for afterwards the bomb
squad is deployed on another bomb
defusing Mission this time the bomb is
inside a car parked illegally in front
of the United Nations building as the
building is being evacuated James puts
on the bomb suit and approaches the car
just as he nears the vehicle a masked
individual from a nearby building shoots
at the car and hates Retreats however
the person's Escape is short-lived as he
is quickly apprehended by the soldiers
James utilizes a fire extinguisher to
put out the flames and proceeds to
examine the car while Owen and Sanborn
assume their positions as a lookout in
the next scene James unlocks the trunk
and discovers several artillery shells
similar to the ones he encountered
before after a few moments he decides to
remove his bomb suit entirely realizing
it offers no real protection it becomes
apparent that the explosive in the car
is potent enough to cause widespread
casualties including his fellow soldiers
even if they seek cover with this
realization James believes that
discarding the suit will at least
provide him with a more comfortable
death and he won't look like a friggin
idiot he then proceeds to disarm the
shells and meticulously searches the car
for the triggering device a task that
takes several minutes at one point
Sanborn attempts to communicate with
James through a headset but our hero
finds it distracting so he throws away
the device meanwhile Owen and Sanborn
observe several groups of Iraqis
watching them from rooftops and
demeanorette and including a person who
is recording their actions with a video
camera eventually James locates the
triggering device in the car and safely
removes it successfully concluding the
mission he then returns to his vehicle
and lights a cigarette to unwind but
soon receives a punch from Sanborn for
not acknowledging him during the
operation next time you do it Sanborn
you later that day Colonel Reed
approaches James clearly impressed by
his composure and ability to handle such
a high stress situation the colonel
inquires about the number of bombs he
has disarmed till this date and James
confidently provides an exact count of
873 legendary the next day the team
Ventures into the desert in order to
carry out controlled detonations of the
collected explosives from previous
missions shortly after James realizes he
left his gloves near the blast zone so
he quickly drives back to retrieve them
during his absence Sanborn contemplates
triggering a bomb to kill James
intentionally and disguise it as an
accident however Owen manages to
persuade him against such an unethical
act after completion of their task the
team is heading back to the City when
they come across two parked SUVs with a
group of armed individuals Sanborn gets
off the vehicle and commands them to
lower their weapons the men comply and
one of them reveals himself as a British
Commando asserting that they are on the
same side he then seeks help with a flat
tire and the bomb squad agrees to lend a
hand while repairing the tire a
wrenchman is unexpectedly shot in the
back the team is caught off guard as
gunfire erupts around them prompting
everyone to seek cover soon after
another British Commando is killed while
Manning the Hummer's machine gun the
British team leader positions himself as
a sniper on a small Rocky Hill and
begins to retaliate targeting a stone
made Hut from where the enemy sniper and
their group are firing however while
adjusting the rifle's bipod the leader
is fatally struck in the chest by the
enemy sniper after this Sanborn takes
over the sniper position while James
uses a powerful scope to assist him in
locating the enemy after firing several
shots Sanborn runs out of ammunition so
James instructs Owen to search the
pockets of the deceased Commando
although Owen finds a full magazine the
bullets seem to have become jammed due
to the man's blood as a result James
steps in and whips out that sweet bow
and arrow I mean he cleans the magazine
himself after this James and Sanborn get
back to their positions and eliminate
the enemy combatants one by one finally
claiming Victory later that night the
guys have a party at James's living
quarters engaging in playful chest
pounding and indulging in drags during
this time Sanborn discovers James's
collection of components gathered from
nearly every bomb he has disarmed James
explains that he keeps them as reminders
of the ever-present danger he faces on
their next mission Colonel Cambridge
accompanies the bomb squad to a building
where bomb making materials have been
reported upon reaching there Cambridge
remains outside while the team conducts
a search within the premises inside they
discover the supplies used to
manufacture bombs along with evidence
indicating that the perpetrators have
recently fled in one of the rooms James
comes across the lifeless body of a
young boy with a large incision on his
chest upon a closer look he recognizes
him as the little seller from earlier
Beckham James and instructs sanbornino
and to vacate the building as he needs
to examine the boy's body for bombs
initially overwhelmed by Soro James
eventually controls himself and proceeds
to dissect the boy's abdomen retrieving
explosives hidden in plastic he then
carries the deceased boy outside and
places him in a vehicle meanwhile
Cambridge continues his efforts to clear
the locals from the surrounding area
James calls out to him urging him to get
into the vehicle but a sudden detonation
from another improvised explosive device
claims cambridge's life instead
witnessing this tragic event Owen
struggles to accept cambridge's death
and aimlessly searches for him but James
manages to comfort him on the following
day James talks to the merchant with
whom Beckham used to work he inquires
about Beckham's whereabouts but the
merchant feigns ignorance claiming that
he doesn't understand English suspicious
that the merchant is potentially leaking
their internal information James decides
to take action so he forcefully jumps
into the Merchant's truck and asks him
to drive towards Beckham's house the
terrified man does his asked and he
drops James at the location before
hastily fleeing upon entering the house
James finds a guy in the kitchen who
appears frightened but surprisingly
welcoming he demands information
regarding Beckham's location but the man
is unaware this is when James realizes
that the merchant has taken him to the
wrong place as he's about to leave he
stumbles upon the man's wife who reacts
with anger and begins berating him for
his intrusion James navigates his way
back through the city towards the
military base passing numerous locals
who appear visibly upset upon reaching
the main gate he identifies himself as a
U.S soldier and makes up a false story
claiming he had been at a whorehouse
later that night the team receives a
call to investigate another bomb
explosion site as they arrive they
discover that a bomb likely from a
suicide bomber had detonated near an oil
tanker truck resulting in the deaths of
several residents James assesses the
perimeter of the blast area for a while
and forms a theory that the bomber did
not commit the unthinkable but instead
triggered the explosion from a location
outside the perimeter filled with anger
James vows to locate the bomber and
directs his comrades to conduct separate
searches in nearby alleys shortly after
James and Sanborn hear a gunshot from
where Owen is located so the two rushed
to his Aid they witness Owen being
dragged Away by two unidentified men in
response they pursue the kidnappers and
shoot at them killing them on the spot
but during the commotion James
inadvertently shoots Owen in the leg in
the morning James and Sanborn rendezvous
with Owen at the helicopter which is
about to transport him to the hospital
Owen expresses bitterness towards James
for accidentally shooting him stating
that his femur is shattered and Recovery
will require several months he also
chastises James for putting his
teammates in difficult situations solely
to satisfy his personal Vengeance the
scene then cuts to another mission where
James and Sanborn arrive to find a lone
man standing in the middle of a large
Plaza with his body padlocked with
several bombs the man pleads for Mercy
emphasizing that he has a family James
approaches the man and discovers that
the bombs have a two-minute timer he
frantically attempts to cut the locks
but realizes that there are simply too
many of them this leaves James with no
option but to apologize to the man and
run away seconds later the bomb
detonates claiming the man's life and
propelling James away Sanborn rushes to
the scene fearing that James has
suffered the same fate as Matt but
fortunately he is only stunned and
eventually regains his composure during
the drive back to the base Sanborn who
is still shaken by the incident confides
in James expressing his fear of dying in
Iraq without even experiencing the joys
of marriage or Parenthood in response
James Souls his friend assuring him that
he will make it back home and have the
opportunity to start a family unless his
dick gets blown off by a bomb finally
the team's rotation comes to an end and
James returns to his home and family
however he struggles with the Simplicity
of civilian life and finds it
challenging to readjust he should try
defusing arguments on Twitter he'd feel
right at home as a result he makes the
decision to return to Iraq no one told
him about Twitter in the final scene
James is depicted as part of a different
bomb disposal unit and he goes on a new
Mission continuing his passion for
defusing bombs and saving lives
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching